our abs all right is this working is
this working everybody I gotta check
because sometimes I'll be live and I
won't even I'll be talking and
what'll happen
is
I won't even be alive because I'm really
bad at the equipment uh hopefully
blessing is watching right now and
making sure that I'm live you know I'm a
woman so I like can't do things as you
know uh let's see oh no I need to change
this thumbnail freaking all right hold
on guys
hold on hold on I gotta I gotta figure
this out but while I'm typing let's talk
about
let's talk about the topic today so
I'm gonna give you my opinion on what
men
look for in men value now I'm not
talking about all high value men right
because I grew up around
a specific type
of high value men okay I grew up around
upper middle to upper class
Suburban people
all right
and
I'm just going to go through a couple
things that if that's the type of guy
you want to go for I would say most of
the people I grew up around made around
70 plus okay
okay
now
because it's and these a lot of these
are super basic that I'm going to go
over but it's weird I'll say these
things and they're like a surprise to
some people so I'm just going to go
through them this this stream is for the
girls fellas fellas get out of here
fellas people say I'm not I'm not for
the ladies you know hold on I gotta I
gotta switch this thumbnail I wonder let
me see if my thumbnail guy is live
um could let me see if I can get them on
the phone
uh let's see
let's see let's see
because
all right hold up let's see
and if you're gonna say I'm disorganized
the answer is I know
I know I'm disorganized look at that's
with me hey Chris
um are you busy now could you switch my
thumbnail for the live
okay
okay um just put put something that goes
with the title
um
I'm gonna talk about the things that
high value men look for in a wife so I
don't know something that goes with that
okay thank you
okay bye
all right he's good he's good all right
so hopefully
we're gonna change this in a second
so all right guys today let me see if I
can share my screen
okay wait wait I thought I make this big
and also we're still working on getting
the chat on the screen so I can look at
the same time but
for now for now
now I really should script these out a
bit more but guys I'm just an unpolished
gal all right look I might get some hate
for this I might get some slack for this
but I'm just an unpolished girl all
right so let's talk ladies ladies ladies
ladies all right this one is for you now
how do I make myself
a second
okay you guys can see me okay
so what are the things that high value
men look for now again
these are going to seem basic to the
average person I'm Gonna Make This Big
now and when I think of these men I
think of people like like my older
brother right he's in his mid to late
20s he's already making six figures you
know
um I think of my parents they're around
I've been to private banking events I've
been
around and this isn't this isn't like
the entertainers the athletes this is
the type of guys that you want to settle
down with the guys that go
get a wife and a family get some land
they might even not cheat on you all
right I'm not saying all of them you
know I know everyone in the comments is
gonna say pearl Pearl they're going to
cheat on you no matter what if that's
your view fine but this if you want a
Suburban
middle to Upper to Upper upper class Guy
this is what they look for so one
no tattoos
oh my gosh this blessing calling me it's
my sound off
hello
[Music]
already so I'm going to send me an email
uh and then we can just pay for them
from the studio
oh okay that's fine so you can pay when
you get back here I'm streaming I
thought you were calling me about an
audio issue
oh no no okay is there anything urgent
or you just you can talk to me when you
get back all right I was giving I was
given a whole speech
don't feel bad it's okay oops okay okay
bye
oh my gosh everyone it's like everyone's
trying to call everyone's trying to call
Pearl okay
all right y'all
so number one thing guys
from this background
do not like tattoos on their women all
right
when you put especially if it's some if
you guys need to get tattoos okay if you
are dying you just gotta get a tattoo
put it somewhere that no one can see it
now my mom told me this growing up I was
like Mom why are you so judgmental why
do you
why do you care so much about what other
people think
guys mom was right mom was right all
right and now I have a sister that
didn't listen to this
okay so get get rid of your tattoos
ladies those are not necessary okay two
no tattoos number two okay
this is going to be controversial I
don't even know if this is controversial
I know that we always say in general men
don't care what you do okay
and in general that is absolutely true
okay
however
your hobbies cannot be
going to the bar wait wait
Hobbies cannot be
going to the bar every weekend
and going out all the time
looking
like a hoe
they don't want their girl doing that
okay I understand that maybe you might
need to go out to meet someone okay but
if your Instagram oh that we're gonna
get into Instagram next okay Hobbies
cannot be going to the bar every weekend
and going out all the time looking like
a
it just can't be okay if you know my
brother lived in Wisconsin okay and the
girl that he's gonna marry they
definitely like to drink together
but they go out together all right you
can't find anything on her social media
okay
Hobbies cannot be going to the bar every
weekend and looking like a hoe
that cannot be it
guys don't like tattoos
okay
in these circles
you could have makeup and you can have
work done okay I'm not gonna say that
doesn't happen like clearly
but it cannot be extreme so you cannot
no heavy makeup
makeup
eyelash extensions
are seen as trashy no heavy makeup super
no super heavy
eyeliner
okay
none of that none of that okay because
again so I'm just thinking of my brother
a lot of the guys that make a lot of
money guys or my dad right I'm thinking
if my dad was out on the market again
you know he's a top one percent earner
thinking of my brothers who are probably
top five percent roughly you know for
their age group if they're out on the
market and they were looking for well I
mean my bro
three of my brothers are actually top
top five percent earners a lot of their
friends all are okay they're on the
market all right they're looking for a
wife
they don't want a lady that's super high
maintenance like they don't want a girl
with the look
they probably would prefer grow more
high maintenance than me all right
I'm just telling you what the guys say
they want they want you to look nice
they want you to look put together but
what they don't want is heavy makeup
eyelash extensions
um super heavy eyeliner they don't want
oh a close a shopping addiction
because when guys look at this let's say
let's say show I'm not I'm not gonna say
the show sauce cast and you say it takes
2 000 a month to maintain you okay
even a guy that has money
he doesn't want to spend 2 000 times 12.
that's half that's 24 000 a year even if
a guy's making six figures he doesn't
want to spend 25 of his salary on your
ass you know like he knows you're gonna
spend money but they really want girls
is this
is this too big I feel like this needs
to be smaller okay we're gonna
because I want I wanted to make it big
all right we're gonna go back 46
th oh shoot
all right good so they don't want a girl
with a bunch of tattoos guys ladies if
you're young watching this do not do not
get any tattoos guys don't like that
um your hobbies cannot be going to the
bar every weekend
um going out all the time looking like a
hoe that's just not a good look guys you
could be a perfect like I've had so many
girls that carry themselves so well on
my show and then after I look at their
Instagram and it's just ass pic boob pic
boob pic like guys men from where I'm
from I'm not saying every now and then
they'll be a sucker okay simps are in
every wealth category all right so I'm
not saying it can't happen
but in general these men don't want
girls
that have their butt all over Instagram
that are in bars every weekend they'll
Maybe
you know
when you're younger you know I mean I'm
I'm thinking of my I'm thinking of my
family like you know
in college fine
you know
but you can't be the drunk you always
gotta you gotta move classy okay they
don't want a girl that's been banged by
the whole school all right
okay so no heavy makeup no eyelash
extensions no super heavy eyeliner they
don't want a girl that's a has a
shopping addiction
um
okay let me let me just check the chat I
know I ain't been checking the chat okay
I'm
okay they put it on Members Only
oh yeah
four
here's things no
piercings except ears
ladies ladies all right
men don't want all right the ear
piercings here wait wait I gotta I gotta
show okay here okay here okay
here not okay not okay here not okay
here not okay
any of those weird big ass holes in your
ears not okay guys that looks trashy
let's just
female piercings
images
does this look good to you
does this scream wife do you want your
mom picking you up from school with this
is this what you want
tongue piercings no no oh my God I wish
to God my brother would bring home a
girl with a tongue piercing I wish to
God I mean
you know sometimes in our family we've
had moments but in general look it
because again again
men look for Purity all right and when
they look at you
the more stuff you've had done to your
body
the more
the more they're just gonna think you're
a I'm gonna be honest okay the
more the more heavy makeup you have the
more sexual makeup like when you make it
super heavy the more tattoos you have
um the more
piercings you have
uh the more butt pictures you have on
Instagram to me this is basic I didn't
even think I need to do a stream on this
but
yeah oh this is a good one Doug Doug
thank you for your contributions in the
chat you have been one of my day one
supporters from the very beginning
um Doug is very important to the channel
he's one of my top moderators all right
um
my brothers again you guys can take this
or leave it all right they're from a top
one percent family
their girlfriends
one one's married one's engaged one is
like in his early 20s but he's got a
long-term girlfriend right okay
they really don't want high maintenance
women they want women that are
comfortable in their skins comfortable
going out with no makeup hair in a
ponytail they want you to be able to get
ready
in 30 minutes
I'm sorry could I make this a little
smaller just uh
yeah all right
um okay wait I need to hide hold on hold
on
let me fix this so you guys can see it
um
okay wait
on all right
here we go
be able to get ready in 30 minutes
or less
okay they don't they don't
how annoying it is I find it annoying as
a woman okay I can't even imagine as a
man do you know how annoying it is
because a lot of these guys they might
want to take their family or if you're
in a top one percent family do you know
what we do for vacations we go skiing
okay do you know what it's like to have
a girl
that needs a full face of makeup to go
I don't know
skiing
like Diane
Diane we're we're going on a slope with
the mask on why do you need this much
makeup guys and
they don't like women that lie and when
you're when you're putting on a ton of
makeup you got you got fake hair you got
fake nails you got heavy makeup oh
that's another one I'm gonna add that to
my list
I'm sorry it you're a liar you're a liar
because you don't look like you it's
okay to have a couple natural
enhancements all right let's not pretend
that none of the Suburban moms get BOTOX
all right let's not pretend that none of
none of them have anything like fake
nails or anything okay
but a lot of these people in Middle to
upper class families want to go on
active vacations hiking biking
guys you guys think these
look okay
again who is Diane there's no one named
Diane I just makeup names sometimes okay
um
okay be able to get ready in 30 minutes
or less
um
what was my next one
oh
six
all right let's go to six
oh wait how do I
I want to make it okay I want to make it
like
a new page all right
do not be an idiot okay
all right this is this is gonna be
offensive to the teaching Majors okay
this is going to be very offensive
this is going to be offensive okay
one of my brothers wouldn't date
teaching majors
one of my brothers he refused today
there was a girl that he thought was so
attractive
so attractive
okay
she was feminine
she was into him all the stuff and do
you know why he said he wouldn't date
her
she was an education major now
this is gonna differ you know it's one
thing if maybe you're an education major
to homeschool your kids okay that makes
sense but in general look it
my brother my brother he went for an
engineer because she was smart guys
smart men don't want idiot women to
raise the children
okay like they're not attracted to it in
the same way we are like if if we see a
man okay and we find him attractive and
he's really smart it makes them hotter
to us
now guys are not the same you're not
going to be hotter to him because you're
smart and by the way smart does not mean
a PhD it does not mean any sort of
formal education none of that it
just means having basic common sense and
if you don't have basic common sense you
should go be around some people that do
because
that's something your parents should
teach you and if they haven't I think
you need to go around some people with
some common sense all right
teachers talk to everyone like it's
their children
it's annoying even their husbands or
boyfriends true
education Majors is that what we call it
now we used to call them mouthy broads
so don't don't be an idiot so let's just
recap okay let's just recap things that
men
things that men don't want all right one
no tattoos guys ladies ladies please I
am so tired of this I need to hold on I
just need to go back I am so tired of
seeing eyes on the show okay and we'll
have a woman that is stunning she is
beautiful and if she played her cards
right she could get
a rich attractive man because she is
that attractive okay
not everyone's born with that okay not
everyone's born with that ability but
these girls and they have a winning
lottery ticket in life and what they'll
do is they'll get a bunch of tattoos
maybe even a sleeve
and then they're confused why you date
bums
guys the guys that like tattoos in
general
don't have jobs don't shoot the
messenger okay don't don't don't shoot
the messenger okay
yeah yeah they don't
all right
your hobbies
cannot be going to the bar every weekend
going out all the time looking like a
hoe
no heavy makeup eyelash extensions no
super heavy eyeliner no shopping
addiction okay
no piercing except your ears you can't
get your ear piercing I think some guys
might no belly buttons no no no no be
able to get ready in 30 minutes or less
low maintenance
um let's talk about Fitness
all right we have don't be an idiot okay
do not be a
I can't say it on here
a beautiful Majestic creature
I don't know how to spell okay a
beautiful Majestic creature
there's this one girl that came on my
show
and
I remember thinking I remember thinking
wow this girl has such a pretty face
she was born with such a pretty face
that even though she was 220 to 250
pounds
she was still attractive I think most
guys still would not proudly okay not
not proudly
but I asked a couple guys and they're
like
yeah yeah
but this girl ruined it you guys think
you guys think that men like these slim
thick women
guys all slim thib all slim thick means
it's butt and thighs that's it okay when
guys say slim thick or they like thick
women they like big women they mean butt
and thighs they don't like your guts all
right they don't like your big gut
hanging off they don't like
all the flab everywhere they just want
you in shape so and a guy wants to think
Hmm will she stay in shape they will
look at your mother
they will they're gonna they want to see
how you're gonna age
because they're
someone says 220 pounds in in at 9 00 PM
out by five five am okay fine fine
they want to see how you're gonna age
okay because
men don't want to buy something and it
gets fat later so if your mom's fat
maybe don't introduce them to your mom
too quick maybe wait on that one okay
maybe wait on that one
all right
do not be oh I can't see I can't I can't
spell a beautiful Majestic creature okay
I'm gonna take off my sweater
all right my it's a little it's a little
warm in here okay
um
in particular what they would like is a
girl with
a fitness routine
or involved in some kind of fitness
they want to know
is that is there is it gonna buy okay
like if they buy if they buy you you're
the product
how are you going to look over time okay
next thing good with kids
I saw a tweet the other day
and oh my gosh I need to turn off my
notifications during during these
streams okay
tweet the other day that a guy on a date
to test women will say I want 13
children
he wants 13 children but just because he
wants to see her answer
one girl says oh wow 13 children ah
the other girl says oh
I can't wait to get started when when do
we start you know
so you know
if you have little siblings that's a
plus if you if you're good with children
that's a plus
all right
knows how to cook
now I think a lot of us women think we
know how to cook
okay we think we do all right I I'm a
decent cook I'm working on it but let's
just let's just be real ladies and ask
yourself this in the last week how many
home-cooked meals from scratch have you
made this week
now if you can name three or four
congratulations ladies
but if you can't
you're not working on it
you don't know how to cook and you're
just saying you know how to cook because
you know how to put some seasoning on
some chicken and throw it on the stove
let me know in the chat guys let's let's
let let's let the chat do one
let's let the chapty one also guys I'm
going to take a little a little
Interruption here I'm gonna put
Google forms okay guys if if you enjoy
this community because I really am
trying I have visions for this channel
okay I really
would like to do matchmaking I would
really like to do events where people
that are similar can like you know get
together
um I'd really like to do
a lot of that sort of stuff so okay hold
on I gotta copy this
foreign
so if you guys are interested in the
events that we're going to throw I think
we're going to do a meet up in the next
two weeks
in London
I was gonna do a big one million party
and then I was like I should do one meet
up before I do a bunch I'm also going to
be in the US next month so when I am I'd
like to do meetups in every city I
really want to get this
Community go okay
so if you're interested sign up for the
Google sign up for the Google form give
me your name your phone number and your
email if you don't want to give your
phone number or your email like if you
want to give me one and not the other
that's totally fine just click submit it
shouldn't or put an X and whatever you
don't want to give
um but we got we got some cool things
coming that's one of my goals this year
is to do some events
um I really don't feel like anyone in
the red pill space has done events as
cool as we possibly could so you know
anyways
back to back to back to this okay
okay that's in the chat
do not
okay
do not be a feminist
guys
feminists believe in equality
these men don't want women that are the
their equals they want women that'll
listen to them
okay
um
not be a feminist
why is this not
why is it doing this
oh wait maybe
you guys see this okay well
all right so
we're here no tattoos
Hobbies cannot be going to the bar every
weekend and going out all the time and
looking like a hoe no heavy makeup
eyelash extensions no super heavy
eyeliner a shopping addiction no
piercings except for ears you can do
ears
um be able to get ready in 30 minutes or
less don't be an idiot
um
uh do not be a beautiful Majestic
creature
um they would prefer you to have a
fitness routine of some kind
good with kids oh let's talk about
words to not say anymore
partner
these men don't want to be your partner
do you want a partner or do you want a
husband
it's really common in the UK they always
say oh my partner my partner is that
what you want is that the type of guy
you want you want a partner
do you want a partner you want a husband
okay
I'm trying to think of some other
put put some in the chat come on put
some in the chat guys
oh
knows how to cook add let's add have
your own recipes that's a plus you know
I'm gonna be honest and my family
they want you to be doing something all
right
where I'm from you got to be doing
something if you want to be in the
kitchen you better have your own recipes
if you want to be
anyways anyways
like oh oh this is the other thing we
don't talk about enough I'm gonna
I'm gonna add this as mine
men want women
that work hard but not too hard okay
but not too hard
and at the right things so
they don't want you working so much that
you're stressed of it all the time okay
men don't like stressed out women when
we're stressed we're to everyone
around us nobody likes a stressed out
girl
but they certainly don't want to pay for
you to sit around at the house and do
nothing okay the that's cooked I'm
telling you I wish to God I wish to God
I wish to God my brothers
would have a girl that just wants to sit
around do nothing all of you guys think
oh my gosh the women on the shows now
again this is just where I'm from they
think they think
that being a housewife is oh I just get
to relax
oh
I don't have to do anything all day oh I
can go get my nails done oh I can go get
my hair done these want something in
return
watching the children
cooking for him
my one of my brother's girlfriends she
does all the laundry she cleans the
house she went to culinary school
she's an engineer all of you women that
are like oh I can't do the housework and
and
have a job it's like
this girl she went to culinary school
okay she knows culinary school for fun
while working full-time as an engineer
and doing all the housework
okay
now what what boxes did she tick she was
clean she was organized she knows how to
cook
and she was smart
how do you think why you think she's
engaged right now okay okay all right
um
yeah
have your own yeah but what they don't
want what they don't want they do not
want a girl
that wants a career
more than a family
you really think a guy wants to have
children with you so you can go to work
and start your own business that makes
no money oh my God
oh my goodness it's like half of you
guys will have
average jobs
and you you'll have a business you'll
have a business that makes no money that
you're doing for fun and you would
rather do that
then deal with your kids now look it
look it
if you're bringing in a million dollars
a year on your business
okay that's one thing but you guys are
making like fifty dollars a month and
you're like oh this is more important
than my kids he's holding me back how
how is he holding you back
okay
wow 52 of women in stem Fields go to
part-time or change Industries after
they have their first child
all right let's keep going
okay words that men don't want to hear
you say
um they're sick of hearing about your
horoscope signs
um
looking for a connection are you looking
for a connection are you looking for a
husband
okay it's it's one or the other all
right
um
trying to think of some of the words oh
energy I am so trauma I'm so sick of
hearing about your energy
I am so sick of hearing about the
connection I'm so sick of hearing oh
what's your zodiac sign I
and I'm mostly sick of Auntie Can attest
to this I am sick of hearing about your
trauma toxic masculinity these are just
words we need to take out of our
vocabulary toxic masculinity
toxic masculinity okay
it could be a this could be a stream in
itself all right
my truth
it's the truth what is that true not my
truth
okay so let's let's go through these one
more time ladies
partner are you looking for a partner
you're looking for a husband horoscope
signs looking for a connection you might
as well just say I'm I'm for the streets
okay
energy oh oh here's another one
healing
what the hell are all of you guys
healing from
did you go to war
when I think of healing okay I think you
either got injured or yeah
or oh you know what else I'm sick of
hearing about your goddamn narcissist
ex-boyfriends
abusive abusive ex-boyfriends
like I'm sorry you guys cannot all have
had narcissist ex-boyfriends you cannot
have all had abusive ex-boyfriends I
don't believe you I'm also sick of
hearing
guys if you didn't file a police report
if you didn't file a police report
I have a hard time believing the grapes
okay look it
this just sounds like a lot of headache
for a guy you know if that actually
happened to you if that actually
happened to you I have a lot of sympathy
okay and I really do I genuinely
however I'm just I've been hearing about
this way too much it can't be happening
to all of you it can't be happening to
all of you so
being too drunk at a party does not
count it doesn't count okay
um I'm really sick of see how this is
just coming from me but
I think I've let this go off a little
bit I'm also sick of hearing
about don't judge
okay does a guy want a mother that's not
judgmental to his kids
because at the end of the day the world
is going to judge you and the world most
certainly is going to judge your
children I am so thankful that I grew up
with a judgmental mother okay I'm sorry
Jennifer
sorry Mom she was okay and
she would always tell me don't get fat
don't get tattoos don't get this don't
get this don't sleep around don't do
this don't do this and at first when I
was young I was like what mom you're so
judgmental and thank God because I
avoided tattoos I avoided piercings I
avoided a lot of poor decisions that
other people were making because I had a
mother in my ear all the time
judging
judging and guys don't judge
another word we need to retire yeah but
they want to hear men want to hear yes
sir
yes yes honey yes babe not yeah but
[Music]
they don't want to hear that but modern
women just want to say whatever we want
look it guys I understand we got to talk
about our feelings okay this is the one
thing men don't understand about us when
we're frustrated or we're mad we need to
talk to you or we need to talk to
someone else
okay that's just how that's just how
women are we're going to talk to someone
but guys go to your girlfriends go to
get one or two close girlfriends go to
them you don't need to be going to the
whole town
oh my gosh manifesting when I hear the
word manifesting
this is what I hear this is what I hear
I want to do no work
and get the outcome so manifesting a man
I don't want to look for a man I don't
want to work for a man but I want the
man
manifesting being a millionaire I
manifested it I don't want to do the
work to become a millionaire I have no
plan to become a millionaire
but I want to become a millionaire
guys
oh
as a woman
we know what your gender is
I'm so sick of hearing oh as a woman
do you oh
are you blind
are you
oh do you know what else I'm sick of in
my last relationship what went wrong in
your last relationship
I did too much
basically I did too much and I let him
walk all over me
walk all over me equals equals
oh what does this mean
I like cheaters
and toxic men
and I will choose them
and be toxic as well
and not
admit that I had any part to play
except
quote unquote
giving
too much
like what is this off just so
tired
I'm just so tired
laughs
like some variation of this I did
too much and let him walk all over me I
give too much like there's no
no accountability for what you did
the show has changed me
there were times in my life where I
thought the manosphere was harsh
and then I've listened to you guys women
talk for six months
[Music]
oh oh another one
what is generational trauma
trauma equals generational trauma equals
I make the same mistakes
that my parents made
and I am too dumb
to learn from their mistakes
and instead
I will
make the same mistake
put put the blame on them
I'm so sick of this
so sick of this okay
guys
a smart person learns from other
people's mistakes
I'm not a smart person has to make the
mistake
has to make the mistake and then
learns from it an idiot sees someone
makes the mistake
before them
and thinks hmm I'm gonna make the exact
same mistake and hope that I have a
better outcome
okay
Michelle
distance
there's your answer distance okay now
now
okay
oh you know what else I'm sick of
hearing
in my feminine energy
and women don't have to talk about being
in their feminine energy oh my God I
can't talk
feminine women do not have to talk about
being in their feminine energy
okay the real feminine women that I know
when I think of the women
I
when I think of the most feminine women
now guys I'm not saying I'm perfect I'm
not saying I've never done any of this
stuff what I'm saying is what I'm really
sick of hearing all right so let's let's
go back
this I've never said though as far as I
know sometimes guys sometimes I forget
I'll be like I've never said that
someone will pull up a clip
all right all right in my feminine
energy all of you that are
focused so much on feminine energy are
not feminine most of you are from
households that are not feminine most of
you had no feminine Role Models growing
up and most of you
most of you will then watch some YouTube
videos
talk about soft life
cook a couple meals and declare I am
feminine
are you
are you are you you know
oh another thing
men always stare
and approach me
I have a rule of thumb that says the
women that say that men are always
staring and approaching them never get
approached or stared at
nearly as much as they think
nearly as much
that's my rule that's my rule
um oftentimes they'll take people being
friendly and polite
as staring blah blah blah
okay
the great great Point Doug I will be
submissive
you know we should can I change these to
bullet points
okay I will be submissive for the right
man
feminine women ladies
look
I understand that some men are idiots
and women don't try to make those idiots
into non-idiots
they just keep looking for the the next
masculine man they can find all right
some men I understand you can't trust
Every Man's leadership but in general
Society
look in general Society
incompetent men are not generally are
not in positions that they're not
competent at
I I saw stat the other day that said 60
of women think they can do their jobs
better than their job the better they're
sixty percent of women think they can do
their boss's job better than their boss
and this is what I mean the delusion of
modern women modern women don't want to
work
oh my God I have a story I want to tell
oh I have a story I want to tell so bad
okay I'm gonna tell it I had a certain I
had a certain employee okay
my worst employees I'm gonna be honest
one of the worst employees I've ever had
this employee I had projects
so many projects
got nothing done nothing done I swear to
Jesus I could make a list of all the
things that were not done
this employee asked me
to double their salary
this employee got let go because it
wasn't going to be me anyways my point
is this my point is this
I will be submissive to the right man as
the same reason that employee
believed
this nonsense
you're either submissive woman or you're
not a submissive woman submissive women
work for men
and listen they're not arguing with
their boss submissive women can get
letters of recommendations from their
bosses they tend to get along with the
men in their life
because men like being around a
submissive woman woman oh my gosh
I will be sir what else do we need to
get rid of our vocabulary
what else do we need to do so let's just
just for a little recap
see I think I need to make this smaller
now or we're gonna sometimes these
streams guys I don't even know where I'm
going
um
okay we're gonna make this a little
smaller
Matt okay this is a given but you know
what some girl some some girls it's like
you got to tell them the most basic
stuff
stop using words like men are trash
this equals
I take no accountability
for the part that women play
that myself
or any women play
in society
from in relationships I should I should
put like the negative part
um oh okay let's go he needs
to make six figures equals
I have no emphasis
on character
guys
I've I've been I've
I've dated a millionaire before okay
I really
I don't like putting in too much okay
scratch that scratch that character is
more important than money now a lot of
times money will equate
you know men that work hard tend tend to
make money right but I'm telling you let
me
I'm just not go into that just
look at my new necklace guys it's pearl
necklace
um
I have no emphasis on character
oh I don't want a man
I don't need a man sorry
a man but I want a man
ladies you don't men want to feel needed
so if you say oh I don't need a man but
I want a man it's like
what you do need man so one that's
delusional men Run the World they run
the infrastructure of society and
everything you can do in general Society
like get your car fixed the lights on
the Wi-Fi all that is run by men
so to say I don't need a man but I want
a man you do you do need a man okay
what other guys put it in the chat what
other phrases do we do women need to
exit from their vocabulary if they want
to be taken seriously by high value men
okay
what other phrases
I'm gonna just go through because
there's some new people in the chat what
we've gone through
high value men don't want tattoos
um they don't want a girl that goes to
the bar every weekend and looks like a
hoe they don't want heavy makeup eyelash
extension super heavy eyeliner shopping
addiction they don't want piercings
except your ears they want you to be
able to get ready in 30 minutes or less
low maintenance
um oh you know what I'm gonna add right
here
no super long fingernails
okay don't be an idiot
um don't be a beautiful Majestic
creature a whale sorry Kobe a whale
sorry
my manager says not to say that anymore
a whale look at they can't hold me back
anyways they want you to have some sort
of Fitness routine you're good with kids
you know how to cook don't be a feminist
don't be a feminist all right
um men want women that work hard but not
too hard and not the right thing so they
don't want a girl that's so career
driven she doesn't want a family but
they don't want you sitting at the house
all day doing nothing what are they
paying for they don't want to pay for
you to do nothing all right
words that we should stop saying partner
horoscope signs looking for a connection
energy trauma toxic masculinity my truth
healing narcissistic ex-boyfriend
abusive ex-boyfriend great accusations
yeah but manifesting
um I did too much and I let him walk all
over me generational trauma
um in my feminine energy men always
stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash he needs to make six figures I
don't need a man but I want a man
okay
my ring needs to cost this much
romantic is that when you're like oh
well my ring needs to be this much my
house needs to be this way having a long
list of Demands that you must have guys
how are you going to trust his
leadership if you want to lead how much
you spend in the relationship
that's not submissive for the right man
that's just let's do what I want okay
um
great great addition Ally
oops
you know what we can make that the next
one it's phrases to add
phrases to add to our vocabulary
now before
oh my gosh Financial abuse
great great input Doug
how can you how can you be financially
abused if he was paying the bills I
don't want to hear
I don't want to hear you you can
get you you if you choose to let him pay
all the bills okay
you don't get to have your cake and eat
it too if if you want a backup plan
ladies then be a working wife then be a
working wife but I'm so sick of you guys
that get the outcome that all women want
which is to stay at home
okay to stay at home
and then you're gonna whine about
financial abuse
are you kidding me then be a working
wife then be with someone that wants you
to work
life is about choices and trade-offs you
guys just want everything you want him
to make all the money and then you want
to be control and control of the money
that he makes
then go work go work
I have a solution for you oh well I
can't do that
well I can't do I can't do all the work
of having a Roomba using the air fryer
why is this blurry
blessing on blurry my camera I don't
know how to fix this
I don't wanna that's just like basically
let me let me have it all okay what
how do I hold on hold on
okay
let me see if this fixed it
better okay
[Applause]
okay now let's add phrases to add to our
vocabulary okay
now guys I have a lot of sympathy a lot
of women we haven't been taught this
a lot of men don't even know what they
want from women to be honest like if you
ask guys
what do you want from your girl cook
clean
be nice be in shape we all know it's
more than that
but they don't know how to describe it a
lot of them so like here's some phrases
to add to their vocabulary okay
oh actually I have one more to get rid
of sorry this list can go on and on I
became traditional
no I became feminine well what did you
do to become feminine oh well I watched
some podcasts and read some books and
I just think you guys just want to do
nothing if I'm being honest
that like that's just my okay phrases to
add
I
I trust you
I trust you so if he makes a decision
you don't like
and you want to kill them and you're
like babe I cannot believe you bought
that two hundred thousand dollar sports
car we need
I trust you all right babe I trust you
okay
there's someone else that is something
good in the chat
someone else hold on let me put
oh I support you
thank you
have your back
I'm making blank
for dinner tonight
honey
if no one died
oh shoot I'm just reading
yeah
so guys so
oh
this is just some basic stuff
what men look for guys I really
appreciate you all watching these
streams you know it's funny I've been
doing the YouTube thing for a while okay
but I've mostly been moderating shows
and doing reactions and I'd really like
to do a couple more monologues a couple
more streams but I get a little nervous
nerves all right like you know you gotta
you gotta plan out these whole things
and I
I'm just trying to get better and better
and better so I just I really appreciate
the support I see the super chats all
right let me let me read some of these
thank you Pearl you and Auntie Jenny
helped me Kiera
you know two dollars all right I don't
care how big how small there's 600
people watching all right
nobody had to give a Super Chat there's
so many people that just watch for free
they'll watch me all the time for free
no hey I'm one of those free Watchers a
lot of the times on a lot of people's
Channel
but you know I appreciate it from the
bottom of my heart okay Saint Jim Pearl
is spitting facts right now dropping
bars thank you I try
I'm also going to welcome our new
members Saint Jim
all right thank you for joining Melody
mush
Saint Jerome
and came all thank you very much for
joining the chat we have a fun little
Community going here
fun little Community going on in here
and
I really appreciate you guys being a
part of it
another thing is if you would like to be
notified when we do events in different
cities we're going to start doing
meetups it's not going to be anything
crazy to start I had all these big ideas
and I was like you know what I need to
do step one before 10. I'm gonna do
meetups in each City that I go to I'll
just find a bar or coffee shop and just
say hey guys come here
and you guys can just put in your phone
numbers and your email and you'll be
alerted of our
schedule of where we're gonna be okay I
will have security no weird stuff
respectfully another two dollar Super
Chat love your content come to Atlanta
we need you I am going to Atlanta this
next trip so you better sign up for the
email list
in in the comments it's the pin comment
okay
um I'm going to Atlanta I will likely do
a meet up in Atlanta
um
I am moving back to the US the plan is
to move back to the US in the fall that
is my goal
that is my goal that's where I want to
be us USA
okay
I love Pearls of Wisdom Emily
I've seen you in this chat before Emily
thank you so much thank you all right
again I appreciate this from the bottom
of my heart you could just be a free
Watcher two dollars ten dollars
whatever it is all right
you guys are my people all right yo
you're my people okay
sometimes you guys know things about me
we would love to have you in the Twin
Cities Charlie Brown
I will not be in the Twin Cities anytime
soon but but all right come on it's not
that far from Chicago and I will be
doing a meet up in Chicago so sign up
for the email list and my long-term goal
I really would like I know the ladies
hate me okay but I would really like you
to join the community so we can get some
like-minded ladies all right and some
like-minded men together and do some
meetups you know I think that would be a
lot of fun okay I think that would be a
lot of fun
um also I'm gonna be hosting a red pill
boxing match I think I found a
conservative and a liberal okay maybe
this is conservative versus liberal but
I'm trying to get the red pill versus
blue pill so if you have any people that
would do boxing
um let me know because I'm gonna host it
and that's going to be in Chicago so
sign up if you want that to be updated
too let me know in the chat
um
okay
love you come to Austin look who knows I
could I could move to any City to be
honest I can move to Chicago my plan is
Chicago now but I could move to Atlanta
yeah
I could move to Austin
I could move to Twin Cities you know it
could be anywhere
all right how would women degrade other
women and why is the first thing they
attack body count status in and behavior
because it's the easiest thing to insult
all right guys let me just go through
this again one more time for you
one more time welcome Ella for something
all right
move to pull okay I can tell you where
I'm not moving and that's Poland all
right
if I was going to advise someone
that wants to get to the upper get with
the upper class to wealthy men that I
grew up around this is what I would tell
the women
don't get any tattoos
your hobbies cannot be going to the bar
every weekend and dressing up like a hoe
you know they don't mind a girl that
goes to the bar here and there okay
they like a girl that's fun okay that's
gonna go out with them do things with
them
but what they don't want
is a girl that's dressed like a hoe
there's a difference between you know
going to the bar
with your brothers a couple girlfriends
and go into the bar with your ass cheeks
out and you're taking pictures all night
no guy wants to go out to a bar or go to
a club or whatever with you and you're
just taking pictures of the food you're
taking pictures of your butt and he's
got to take the picture like
my family and people that I grew up
around would not want to date you if you
have heavy makeup eyelash extensions
heavy eyeliner and a shopping addiction
guys they're making calculations about
how much it costs now
one percent two percent of men aren't
gonna care that much but how many of you
are really going to get that okay so
let's let's talk about guys seventy
thousand to two hundred thousand roughly
a year okay what I grip around now my my
dad
was hot look let's not count each
other's Pockets never mind but look it
even my dad my family well we grew up
around they are they're thinking how
much do you cost and are you worth it
okay
so when I'm on these shows and these
girls are saying they need two thousand
dollars a month to maintain maintain
themselves
maybe you guys are just in different
circles just where I grew up around
my family would look at you like your
crazy maintain what oh you know
what let's put that on the phrases to
get rid of I need a man to maintain me
what are you a child what are we
maintaining sorry okay let's go back up
back up
get ready in 30 minutes or less look at
in the circles I'm from family vacations
involve doing activities skiing a lot
like one percent family ski we ski and
you know what's annoying to have on the
ski resort some that's doing her
hair
lady we're skiing we have masks on
what do you need 2K a month for I know
okay no piercings except ears
um
no super long fingernails okay
I think guys do like the long like short
ones but they have to look real
everything that you have done it has to
look natural it can't look fake all
right
and a lot of you guys think you look
natural and I swear to God you don't I
swear to God I can see the makeup
melting off your face every show Okay
um
no women can get ready in 30 minutes and
you've been dating the wrong women
I swear to God most of the people I know
30 minutes all right
do not be an idiot
um guys want smart women to raise their
kids
you gotta be smart you gotta be smart
but that what that does not mean is your
PhD or your education you could have a
PhD and be an absolute idiot some of the
most idiotic people I've met are from
smart people places that's why sometimes
guys when I'm like oh I'm not that smart
I just mean some of y'all use big words
for no reason and some of y'all
you just make things complicated anyways
let's just let's just keep going
do not be fat all right don't be a
beautiful Majestic creature okay which
by the way if you want to learn when we
drop our whale merch oh I mean beautiful
Majestic creature merch
um the link is in in the description
we're trying to build out an email list
so if you want to know events everything
email list all right
um good with kids
knows how to cook is a bonus is a bonus
have your own recipes a bonus not a
feminist okay no guy wants to hear about
critical race Theory at three in the
morning
he don't he don't honestly as a girl
that's a bit political I don't even
think men want us to be political at all
whatever
whatever is
um
men and women want women that work hard
but not too hard look at we are never
our best selves when we're stressed out
and they want a girl that cares more
about
oh man I wrote that oh they don't want a
girl that cares more about the career
than the family okay words to not say
partner
now let's let's I I really think we can
make something beautiful here
oh I need to zoom in how do I zoom in on
these Pages do you guys know
[Music]
because I realize this looks big for me
but this is not big for you
okay fine you know what we just need to
get rid of this and I'll just type on
the screen
we don't want stop saying the word oh my
gosh all right
words to eliminate from our vocabulary
partner horoscope signs looking for a
connection energy your goddamn trauma we
don't men don't give a about your
trauma okay if you haven't gone to war
your trauma is not that bad trauma is
not getting cheated on okay it's not
getting cheated on all right toxic
masculinity my truth healing my
narcissistic ex-boyfriend my abusive
ex-boyfriend
um my great accusation that I didn't go
to the police for
you know don't judge don't judge do you
want do you want a mom that doesn't
judge her kids
do you want a mom that doesn't judge her
kids okay we're on the same page yeah
but
do you guys want to hear yeah but or yes
sir
what's better or yes babe what's better
all right manifesting
as a woman we know you're a goddamn
woman we know all right I did too much
and I let him walk all over me
for what went wrong in your last
relationship okay generational trauma
nobody gives a if you saw your
parents make mistakes and you made those
same mistakes that's on you that's on
you in my feminine energy men always
stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash he needs to make six figures I
don't need a man but I want a man my
neat my ring needs to cost this much
Financial abuse I became feminine I need
I need a man to maintain me
great addition we need to vibe
we need to vibe
oh my gosh are you saying we harpoon
whales in the comments
yeah we do we do on just pearly things
okay now phrases to add to your
vocabulary
oh oh that's a great addition we need I
feel like this one this one's pretty
hard we use this a lot
we use this one a lot yeah
yeah okay now let's talk about phrases
to add to our vocabulary ladies
phrases to add to our vocabulary
I trust you I support you
just thought of one
whatever you say
thank you
I'm making blank for dinner tonight
honey
couple phrases we can add
oh I believe or I think
I like you or I love you instead of We
Vibe
oh what can I do for you what can I do
for you great one
do for you
how can I help
I would like to know your perspective on
this
on what Ali
alafayley Allah
phrases to add anyways guys I was just
I was just feeling like talking about my
experience today
oh oh oh another thing that needs to go
I am a traditional woman
when I have when I am a single mother
ladies
traditional women get married and they
get married young
don't shoot the messenger
don't shoot the messenger like it's just
it's just delusional it's just can we
just
this show has changed me it has changed
me guys I've never understood where men
are coming from more in my life than
doing the show
okay so tonight guys
I think that's unless you guys have any
other
any other
things to add in
that's all I got right now I'm sure I'll
think of more I'm sure I will
um thank you so much for the super chats
and all the new memberships guys like
seriously I know that you can watch for
free I watch for free all the time I
can't even fault you for watching for
free
but
when you send me a super chat it's just
it just warms my heart
it just warms my heart in all honesty
because you guys don't have to so I
really appreciate the love I appreciate
the community
make sure you sign up for our
memberships if you want to be a part of
it if not if you don't want to sign up
you don't want to pay for something
every month I get that sign up for our
email list okay and our text list we're
going to text you when we're in
different cities and having meetups
we're going to text you directions where
we're going sometimes guys it's going to
be a last minute meet up okay sometimes
I'm not gonna have time to Market it and
post it so that's why you got to make
sure you're on our email list so if I
take a flight one day to Dallas and I
say hey let's meet up with all the fans
there
you guys can all come
so like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel